أعتقد أنه إذا كان السفر أمرًا مهمًا
لأنه يضيف بريقًا على الهدايا الخاصة بك ، فإن
الإهداء بالتأكيد كمفهوم
ضخم في مشروع الثقافة الإماراتية ، حيث
بدأ كل شيء مع بدء عمله
باستخدام قماش من القماش
ولف الأشياء به ، وقد
فعل اليابانيون ذلك بشكل جميل وهذا هو
حيث انطلقت فكرة المجزرة ،
مابون هو موسم ضخم للهدايا ، لذلك
بالتأكيد يجب أن يكون ما نصممه
من حيث تغليف الهدايا لذلك
الوقت المحدد من العام هو
الذوق أو الروح الرمضانية
فيه.  ربما تم تصميم 10٪ من البطاقات
التي لدينا ولكننا نبحث عن مصممين محليين
وإقليميين ودوليين ،
وعادة ما يكون لدينا ثلاثة أسئلة
لعملائنا ، الأول ما هي
المناسبة ، والثاني هو ذكر أم
أنثى ثم الثالث  يتعلق الأمر أكثر
بالشخص من حيث شخصيته
في حفلات الزفاف ، وعادة ما يكون أكثر
إسرافًا ، لذلك ربما كان
لونه أفتح أو ألوانًا لها علاقة
بالذهب في الإكسسوارات  عادة ما تكون مثل
الإكسسوارات اللؤلؤية أو الأشياء التي تضفي
البريق وربما الاستحمام مرة أخرى ،
يتعلق الأمر بالألوان وهو طفل
يستخدم اللون الأزرق كما لو كانت فتاة تعتقد
أنك لست مضطرًا لذلك بالطبع ولكن هذا هو
ما نفعله في الغالب ومن ثم لدينا  كل
هذه الأشياء المختلفة مع القليل من
الملحقات التي يمكنك إضافتها إلى
هدية
عيد ميلادك تعتمد حقًا
على الشخص الذي تقدم له
الهدية وشخصيته بشكل صحيح ، لذلك
نحن في الواقع عادة ما أطلب ذلك على
المنضدة عندما تأتي إلى  لف
هدية حاول أن تفهم من هو الشخص
وما هي شخصيته مثل
نوع الألوان التي يحبونها ثم نساعدك في
تصميم الهدية بناءً عليها
أنت
[موسيقى]